est ce qu'on appelle un dérapage samedi
matin la chroniqueuse de télématin julia
leigh bages s'intéresser aux
chorégraphes niçois ça décoiffe et à ses
créations mêlant danse et illusion
d'optique
un artiste a décidé de rendre hommage à
la beauté de la nature il s'appelle sa
dette wafi la dernière création la
représentation d'un regroupement
d'oiseaux en plein vol au moment de la
diffusion du reportage on entend une
voix off commenté l'image et comme ils
sont fermés malaise en retour plateau
car il s'agit du présentateur laurent
bignolas sur les réseaux sociaux les
réactions ont été nombreuses sur son
compte instagram télématin a tenu à
présenter ses excuses à ça décoiffe cher
ça décoiffe nous vous présentons de
sincères excuses pour ces mots
totalement inapproprié et
involontairement blessants envers vous
et les téléspectateurs
alors êtes vous choqué par la blague
jugée raciste dans télématin vous avez
quoi fêter avec nous pour nous raconter
comment il a vécu cette séquence
merci ça décoiffe d'être avec nous merci
sort ça décoiffe qui est chorégraphe
cofondateur du groupe géométrie variable
il a même fait une apparition très
remarquée dans le clip de shakira ils
travaillent avec des très grands noms
merci d'être là sadek alors on va voir
cette blague qui a fait énormément
parler d'ailleurs vous l'avez vu un
depuis ça tellement crée le malaise que
télématin et la production télé matin
s'est excusé on va avoir 7 6 et a décidé
de rendre hommage à la beauté de la
nature il s'appelle saad el wafi les
niçois et alors il a décidé de faire une
chorégraphie avec 64 danseurs habillés
de noir et ils reproduisent avec leurs
bras le ballet conséquent l'habitude de
voler mais les grands magasins seulement
il faut me sont fermés on savait que
déjà je vais m'adresser à vous est-ce
que vous avez réagi tout de suite quand
il a fait cette demande ce que ça vous a
dérangé ou pas du tout vous n'avez pas
remarqué en fait bien évidemment je vais
agir tout de suite j'ai regardé ça ce
matin le matin je me suis levé j'ai eu
plein de notification je suis passé dans
télématin le samedi matin je vais voir
avec ma femme et ma fille ou garçon
elle me présente super bien et jacub à
la punchline
vous êtes tout de suite dit qu'il a
digéré mes enfants mais je ne sais pas
c'est quoi la regarde et je me suis posé
la question parce qu'on a l'habitude de
s'énerver un peu vite
bien sûr et du coup j'ai mis un sondage
sur mes réseaux qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
là c'est parti c'était alors justement
maintenant on demande aux
téléspectateurs en direct ce qu'ils en
pensent ce soir guillaume vous vous êtes
choqués et d'habitude c'est pas le cas
banon mais il sait pas possible qu'il
ait dit c'est à l'antenne on dirait
qu'il fait exprès de dire ça pour se
faire virer parce que je rappelle qu'il
est sur la sellette en plus ce land
y'a rien qui va c'est ni drôle ni
approprié français c'est une catastrophe
il faut que france 2 réagissent ils
peuvent pas virer certains animateurs
pour des blagues sexistes sur d'autres
chaînes et garder des animateurs qui
font des blagues attaque sur leurs
propres antennes bah oui si vous êtes
choqués vous csaba oui je suis
profondément choquée après je n'accuse
pas de rats sièges bien sûr qu'il soit
raciste il a voulu faire et un calembour
en fait mais calembours est mal tombé
je vais vous dire la vérité steve et moi
j'ai rien contre oloron binoche je
connais pas du tout mais bon voilà je
pense qu'il fait bien son travail mais
il faut quand même pas là bas je ne sais
pas galant bourges en ressassant avant
là c'est une phrase construit donc que
ça fait référence à des bibles a
complètement nul
non je trouve ça franchement déplacé
jeudi au rabais avec guillaume ils ont
ils ont été beaucoup plus sévères et
d'autres animateurs là il aurait dû
réagir beaucoup plus vite c'est pas
grave à ceux qui ne sont pas choqués
nicolas pernikoff annoncé par rapport au
racisme que je suis pas choqué je suis
bien évidemment choqués par sa connerie
parce que c'est une blague à la con
entre nous je fais rire 3 4 personnes
autour d'une table donc c'est totalement
déplacé bien évidemment mais de l'autre
côté je considère pas que c'est une
blague racisme qui disent directement ça
décoiffe puisque le mec il fait ça un
peu en off sur le plateau final mais oui
oui chez je suis bon il ya des gens qui
disent que c'est pas en direct en
priorité les matins de samedi donc
pourquoi ils ont pas coupé au montage
c'est ce que je comprends pas c'est pour
ça que j'ai 10 ans sur la glace alors
tiffany vous n'êtes pas choquer vous non
parce que pour moi encore une fois je je
je vois pas profond l'accusent de
racisme au risque de paraître naïve ou
un petit peu candide ne me sentais pas
de fait s'il vous plaît il vise personne
ou socrate eu l'idée il vise pas une
communauté l'a particulièrement vous
avez mais tenait merci je pense que il
parle juste des voleurs en général
regardez ils volent la et ben ils
peuvent plus voler dans les magasins
alors et je serai appelé jean durand
avait pas la blague en disant ça je
trouve que c'est nul et maladroit qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ceux à cet
argument salek après moi je les prépare
très personnellement ma couleur de peau
mes origines voilà je l'aï les
magnifiques salles est évidemment quai
laubeuf beaucoup mais je t'inviterai
plus tu es trop beau gosse à dire aussi
que personnellement j'ai rien contre la
personne quand tu nous tiens c'est vrai
je le connais pas bah oui en plus ces
sites ont mis en lumière dans l'émission
donc c'est vrai que c'était lui la cclat
là bas c'est un truc cool et et la jeune
fille qui fait la lancement ils vont
bien valérie non mais moi je
contrairement à tiffany moi je pense
qu'il ya une association d'idées qui
accompagne bien sûr absolument douteuses
donc moi je rêvais pas j'imagine ici
autour de cette table personne n'aurait
l'idée de faire une association d'idées
comme celle ci donc le
tg dérapé j'ai pas fait exprès non c'est
visiblement c'est tout à fait là un truc
comme le dit benjamin maintenant de dire
laurent bignolas est un raciste non et
je pense que a minima il devrait parce
que moi j'ai été aussi déçus d'une chose
c'est que il ya eu des excuses mais qui
ont été faites par le compte officiel de
télématin et pas par laurent bignolas
moi je voudrais aimer que lui sur ses
méthodes personnelles ils disent voilà
j'avais su j'aurais une connerie
donc je le dis pardon je vous demande si
j'ai blessé page de soutien suis navré
gilles verdez je vais pas dire qu'il est
raciste mais c'est du racisme c'est du
racisme qui est terrible parce que c'est
du racisme décomplexé racisme du
quotidien allez je vais balancer ça et
il ya réfléchi ça sort pas comme ça
spontanément il a théorisé ça il sort ça
il dit ça va passer mais non et sur la
télévision publique ça ne peut pas
passer
c'est honteux c'est notre analyse nous
appartient moi je refuse que des gens
comme ça soit sur notre télévision et
maintenant je sais qu'il va partir mais
la rue il doit partir et très vite après
ça je pense que son sort était déjà
scellé après télévision avant mais en
revanche je connais bien laurent il est
d'une maladresse insigne surtout moi je
me sens toujours dans une interview sur
mike brant il a dit il a réussi son
premier vol
extraits donc quand vous savez qu'il est
comme ça sur absolument tous donc c'est
désastreux mais ça n'est pas du racisme
jack dupree seul fait une sortie de
route complètement ratée moi je crois
évidemment l amalgame je pense qu'il
discrimine en dix ans a donc forcément
ces essais c'est très problématique
après je constate aussi que les autres
ont une réaction c'est compliqué parce
que c'est pas en direct comme vous
l'avait dit et malgré tout il ya une
réaction tact et tout le monde est gêné
mais personne non plus sauf sans doute
jusqu'à donc c'est quand même compliqué
voilà la vraie question même si
s'enregistrer c est ce qu il pensait
être à l'antenne ou pas en disant ça
parce que c'est sur un ouf de magnéto il
fait une vanne un pan par galéré tv non
mais s'il pense vraiment être à
l'antenne en disant ça c'est extrêmement
choquant c'est ont bien dû annuler des
revers après leur équipe de production
qui ont pas coupé là exactement oui mais
je pense qu'il est très énervé mais
effectivement je pense que c'était
vraiment les propos ont offensé retrouve
comme un comme ça dès que ce que vous
avez envie de dire aujourd'hui
ben écoute vous auriez mexique qui vous
appelle pour s'excuser ou qui vous
laisse un message il m'appelait bah
voila voila donc c'est qu'il m'a appelé
pour s'excuser c'est cool ça que j'ai
encore une fois voilà j'ai rien contre
la personne découleraient c'est juste le
messager
ce qu'il a dit quoi voilà donc voilà
donc mine de rien vous allez vous a
appelé je n'avais pas bon c'est quand
même l'info voilà laurent bignolas a un
péché n'est qu' aujourd'hui voilà et
c'est vrai qu'ils vous ont mis en
lumière c'est vrai que la phrase était
très très maladroite et vous qu'est-ce
qui vous a dit vous a dit quoi que ce
soit c'est ça que c'était maladroit ce
n'est pas intentionnel n'était pas visé
cible et s'en va l'accord voilà après le
fait que dans ses coups que ça ait pris
cette ampleur quand même parce qu'il
faut que ça s'arrête ce genre de choses
c'est un fait ça c'est ce que disait
gilles tout alors oui j'aurais dit et ça
permet quand même malheureusement de
mettre en lumière le travail de sa dette
qui est juste exceptionnelle ici en
libye
bah merci sadek d'abord avec beaucoup et
si tu cherches des danseurs
[Rires]